so as a normal agent what would for you
for instance do you get any any say in
where you're going and what you're
getting assigned to no they're just
going to give you what they're going to
get not then but then the bureau's uh
policy which made was made complete
sense like starting your life over as an
FBI agent it's a big jump and the
easiest way effectively is to go into
witness security program
to complete new identity no ties to your
old identity at all because it's the
easiest way to become an FBI agent like
nobody nobody you're not around people
you went to high school with you're not
around your neighbors you're not not
even around family oh so you're saying
not literally
like it's witness protection but they
take you they're not going to send you
back to where you're from right they're
going to send you to some other city so
you don't have to run into the people
you used to know you're going to be
right it's a new life that was back then
now the problem with that it was very
expensive